the Board of Governors unanimously voted
the following in appreciation of Excel
his extreme versatility as an actor
singer director and dancer but
specifically because of his brilliant
achievements in the art of choreography
on film the Academy is pleased to
present an honorary award to mr. gene
Keller
mr. Kelly is in Europe at the time and
we are anxiously awaiting to see just
who will come down the aisle and except
for him I believe it's going to be mr.
Stanley Donen it was a co-worker of gene
Kelly's and also a director at MGM and
here he is accepting the award mr.
Stanley Donen
mr. Kelly's co-director and I'm the town
will excite is accepting the award for
him
I'm very sorry gene can't be here
tonight but I'm happy and proud to
accept it for him
thank you our next presenter is an
expert on awards from the receiving end
in top honors of three times three man
the Critics Circle is bowed before him
thrice or members of thrice voted a
picture of his the best of each year and
three times he has received that award
which means more to a Hollywood producer
than any other the Faubourg to present
it tonight
mr. Darryl zanuck
Thank You mr. president it is always a
great honor and privilege to either give
or receive the Irving G Thalberg award
as the best producer of the year what
exactly is a producer I believe it was
Socrates who said a movie producer is
the man who spoiled the picture if the
picture is a failure Plato is alleged to
have said if it was a hit the producer
had nothing whatever to do with it I
have no desire to argue with either
Socrates or Plato there are many kinds
of producers the Irving Thalberg award
goes to a creative producer frequently a
talented individual who also possesses
the ability to organize and coordinate
the talent of others generally the
inspiration for a film good or bad
starts with the creative producer
tonight we break a precedent for the
first time a producer of musical films
is being honored by the Academy a
producer of a musical film works with
many writers and directors on each
individual film the story writers the
music writers the story director the
dance directors etc he is by necessity
the creative center of this particular
project
the man you have selected to honor has
earned his right to be known as a
creative producer his productions this
year alone show Balt an American in
Paris
are perfect examples of creative art mr.
Arthur free
Arthur Creed is coming up in the stage
to receive his most comfortable deal
the Irving Thalberg award
tonight
official ceremonies for the Academy
years
thank you now thank you Charlie for this
honor I'm deeply grateful all I can say
is that the name of Irving Thalberg
twice is the most important name in my
professional life first when I came to
Metro to work with him and tonight when
I hold the award that bears his name in
my hand thank you
Oh am I supposed to do a song here